the as of style still works in marieupol
has become a symbol of ukrainian
resistance
in a network of underground bunkers
civilians and ukrainian soldiers have
been trapped for months as russian
forces close in
hundreds of people have been evacuated
from mariupol including some from inside
the plant
but some civilians and soldiers have
refused or been unable to leave in the
last stand for the steel works
is of huge strategic importance the
southern port city is just over 30 miles
from the border with russia
right in the city centre lies the vast
as of stall steel and ironworks it's a
total maze of warehouses and industrial
facilities and the ukrainians have
defended it from the beginning initially
the russian advance was held back to the
city's outskirts but as the war's gone
on russian forces have closed in
by late april the azov style plant was
the only part of mariupol not in russian
hands
and by may russian forces had cut off
the steel works entirely and begun its
bombardment in earnest
but the site has been the target of air
strikes and shelling since the very
start of the conflict
this footage shows a ukrainian tank
outside one of the main entrances on the
first day of the war
the area now is almost completely
unrecognizable
and while the site was under bombardment
in the tunnels and shelters beneath
civilians were hiding
most of the information coming out of
the plant initially came from ukrainian
sources this footage is said to have
been filmed on march 24th
but by mid-april units allied with
russia began releasing footage from
around the industrial complex
this propaganda video from the donetsk
people's republic's telegram channel
shows them firing in the direction of
the plant
inside the aztel bunkers civilians were
still hiding
the same woman we saw in a video from
march appears again in this clip from
april 23rd
by the time this clip was filmed it
appears she'd been living underground
for at least a month
a bloody standoff between russian and
ukrainian troops was looming
extraction
but on the 21st of april russian
president vladimir putin cancelled any
assault
asking instead for the site to be
completely blockaded
it was after this that the united
nations stepped in to help those still
stuck inside
working with russia they escorted over
100 civilians to the town of zaparisha
and charities like the red cross also
helped with the evacuations
[Music]
but russian airstrikes continued to
pound the complex
and reports of a renewed russian ground
assault on the site surfaced from
ukrainian
officials ukrainian forces however
remain defiant
this video appears to show some singing
patriotic songs at night at the steel
plant
sky news hasn't independently verified
when it was filmed
the battle for mariupol has become one
of the defining tragedies of the
ukrainian war and this sprawling
industrial site has been the last pocket
of resistance
there are heavy bloody battles i am
proud of my soldiers for making inhuman
efforts to contain the enemies onslaught
i thank the whole world for the
tremendous support of the mario pole
garrison
our soldiers deserve it
the situation is extremely difficult but
we continue to carry out the order to
keep the defense despite everything